depuis son éclatement hier l'affairé
richard berry n'en finit pas de faire
parler de diviser accusé d'inceste par
sa fille coline lorsqu'elle avait entre
6 et 10 ans la femme âgée aujourd'hui de
45 ans a décidé de sortir du silence
pour dire sa vérité
dans sa plainte colline berry rochman
indique que lorsqu'elle était enfant son
père aurait abusé d'elle sexuellement
avec la complicité de sa belle-mère de
l'époque la chanteuse jeane manson comme
l'a révélé le journal le monde
quand le couple avait la garde des
enfants en fin de semaine il leur serait
arrivé le matin après leurs ébats de
convier ceci dans la chambre parentale
pour des jeux sexuels des jeux
d'orchestre comme il aurait appelé ça de
son côté richard berry réfute fermement
ces accusations pourtant la fille aînée
de l'acteur persiste et signe
elle est soutenue par sa mère la
comédienne catherine hiégel elle est
aussi soutenu par d'autres membres de la
famille dont l'actrice marilou berry et
sa mère josiane balasko de son côté
joséphine berry la soeur de collines et
fille de l'acteur défend son père il ne
s'est jamais rien passé il n'y a jamais
eu aucune ambiguïté mais qui croire dans
cette histoire alors qu'en france la
présomption d'innocence prévaut enquête
a été confiée à la brigade de protection
des mineurs alors à fait richard berry
etes-vous choqué que la justice se fasse
dans les médias
et vous êtes très très très nombreux à
réagir sur cette affaire oui non je sais
qu'il ya des infos également alors je
vais vous dire voilà ce qu'il y avait
comme contenu dans le journal le monde
d'aujourd'hui qui a publié une enquête
dans laquelle on découvre le contenu de
la plainte et donc des révélations
incroyables quand le couple avait la
garde des enfants en fin de semaine il
leur serait arrivé le matin après leurs
débats comme ils l'ont dit de convier
ceci dans la chambre parentale pour des
jeux sexuels
le père de la plaignante lui aurait
alors proposé du joual orchestre avec
ses organes sexuels et ceux de sa
partenaire
les deux adultes et onu voilà il
d'autres choses voilà qui sont révélés
dans le journal le monde que je vais
vous révéler bien sûr dans un instant où
guillaume genton en enquêtant sur la
sphère j'ai fini un peu sur le compte de
collines berry et sur sa part instagram
vous allez voir il ya une vidéo qu'elle
met elle-même en avant qui est un
passage de richard berry dans l'émission
de tf1 la chanson secrète que j'adore
alors simple il ya un an et en fait
c'est un passage dans lequel il se fait
surprendre par sa petite fille élise qui
est la fille de collier la voir si on
pleure on rit on va la regarder on va
regarder les frais alors s'il vous plaît
merci au fond pas si facile
te faire une surprise qui rime avec
elise
comment
[Applaudissements]
5e quelle comment vous pas ratifié
[Musique]
c'est un casse-tête redire
jeudi connu
je t'aime
alors voila ca s'interdisent c'est la
fille de colis il était à peine majeur
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que pour
participer à l'émission élise a eu
l'autorisation de son père et de sa mère
comme ryanair collines et j'ai eu les
infos colline était dans les coulisses
et qu'apparemment ça se passait très
bien avec richard berry
donc ça pose des questions sur la nature
de leur relation c'est vrai que c'était
il ya un an autre chose en regardant sur
les réseaux sociaux
il ya plusieurs interactions entre
collines et son père qui sont dans la
bonne humeur regarder je vous montrais
quelques messages qui ont été postées
par par coline notamment un médecin une
photo avec ses deux filles photo à
laquelle réagi richard berry raji bon
anniversaire la colline lui répond
amicalement enfin très gentiment merci
papa il ya d'autres échangent entre eux
sur le compte instagram notamment pour
la fête des pères dans lequel elle même
fait bonne fête à son as à son père dont
feraient que ça pose des questions sur
la nature de leur relation
est-ce qu'ils étaient réellement en
guerre ça date d'il ya quelques mois
seulement 21 juin 2021 tradition en tout
cas c'est certain mais c'est [ __ ] en
tout cas guillaume rabault d'avoir voilà
d'avoir trouvé cesser ces informations
par rapport à ce qu'a dit guillaume il
ya des psychiatres psychanalystes qui
m'ont répondu aujourd'hui fin c'est pas
parce que on a l'impression pendant de
longues années où de longs moments que
les relations sont fluides qu'il n'y a
pas ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont comparées
pour moi un volcan un volcan chez elle
qui a éclaté une première fois en 2014
quand elle s'est aperçue que la compagne
de son père attendait un enfant
premier éclatement et puis là ça peut
ressurgir il peut y avoir ce moment le
déclic où elle se dit je vais porter
plainte
et ce sont des moments de pulsions qui
peuvent être des moments de vérité
donc c'est pas parce qu'ils se sont
fréquentés sur un plateau il ya un an de
télé que tout ce qu'elle dit aujourd'hui
il faut il faut faire très attention à
ça d'accord c'est deux choses totalement
différentes selon les psychiatres alors
son avocate l'avocate de richard berry
est intervenu sur ses news voilà dans
les noms des dernières heures on passe
ensuite à la dernière partie où on va
voir les extraits de cette avocate
et elle était avec pascal praud et
regarder ce qu'elle a dit un homme qui
est accusé d'un tel fait où de tels
gestes déplacés qu'il réfute
intégralement et totalement a le droit
de se défendre
ça n'est pas une anomalie ça n'est pas
une violence ce n'est pas un signe de
surpuissance c'est normal c'est le jeu
judiciaire
et c'est normal que nous le fassions et
je trouve que c'est courageux de le
faire parce qu'encore une fois le
tribunal médiatique qui consiste à dire
voilà il y à une accusation dont il est
coupable
vous savez nous quand on plaide me dit
voilà une plainte c'est la preuve de
rien alors il ya d'autres choses aussi
dans le monde
elle explique également dans le monde
avoir été victime d'un voilà je voulais
dire d'un jeu de leur caisse plusieurs
dizaines de fois entre ses six essais 10
ans il me montrait comment son sexe
pouvaient bouger
évidemment j'étais petit je me disais ah
il peut faire bouger son sexe plus tard
j'ai compris que quand un sexe d'homme
bouge c'est qu'il est en érection
c'est vrai qu'il voit là dans l'article
du monde aujourd'hui il ya des infos
après c'est vrai qu'à ce moment c'est un
tribunal médiatique et on en parle ici
depuis deux jours bernard montiel vous
dites oui ça vous dérange est-ce que
vous avez des africains oui c'est
choquant c'est évidemment très choquant
et c'est une bourde terrible âgées pour
qui volent pour avoir le contrepoids
c'est choquant pour tout le monde et
c'est terrible dans cette famille on ne
les aime où l'avait dit tout à l'heure
si je voulais dire c'est que colbert il
a quand même dit que shirel avait subi
également c'est juste alors sur l île à
la vie de personnes ont partagé la même
chambre
à ce moment la cantine manson vivait
avec richard berry est la durée de deux
ans elle n'a jamais vécu ça l'a jamais
fait ça n'est jamais arrivé et c'est
alors que coline a dit que shirel aussi
malheureusement avait été impliqué dans
ces jeux sexuels et airs très récemment
coline a poursuivi shirel par téléphone
en lui disant il faut absolument que tu
me soutiennent dans cette affaire est
tout et shirel l'envoyer valeurs laïques
marilou berry soutenez oui
marilou berry on a percé la laverie
cousine germaine cousine de colline
c'est la ville de collins et la fille du
frère de richard berry josiane balasko
et du frère de richard c'est ça il le
berry qui n'est plus voilà est
exactement ils ont calé et mathieu petit
qu est un ancien compagnon de collines
ni
également ces histoires là ah oui il a
vécu aussi et ça ça vient juste de
sortir l'instant voilà mathieu petit qui
est également le compagnon de mathilde
seigner et denis totalement il dit que
c'est bidon il connaît colline que c'est
pas pour ça qu elle dit oui c'est
possible mais le et les musulmans louise
alors j'ai dit non non mais en fait si
c'est vrai ben c'est immonde et si c'est
faux c'est immonde en fait nous
l'assistent avec à la fois du voyeurisme
et en même temps le genre de fascination
pour le pire on s'immisce dans cette
chambre à coucher
on assiste à des fellations à des viols
à des baisers avec la langue
donc effectivement c'est très choquant
alors pourquoi moi je pense même qu'il
tisse mais finalement il faut qu'elle se
fasse dans les médias c'est parce qu'en
fait elle explique très bien colline
berry elle dit que ça lui permet
d'accéder à une réparation compliqué à
faire valoir devant les tribunaux compte
tenu de la prescription en fait il
s'agit de ça c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
elle ne peut pas avoir justice à cause
de la prescription mais corps et grâce
ou à cause de ce tribunal médiatique
puisque finalement aujourd'hui c'est une
sorte de bataille de la communication
entre les postes et d aider story à
celui qui l'a le mieux se défendre
en fait il ya une enquête qui va être
ouverte et on va pouvoir mais tu as ton
tapis un petit peu comme la sphère
duhamel qui a été un petit peu le début
pour elle le meilleur matériau mais n'y
avait pas d'ambiguïté il est connu il
n'ya pas d'envié
oui c'est pas fait pas bon j'avoue que
staline non je trouve que tu as quoi tu
as raison ce donc dans les deux cas
c'est c'est horrible mais effectivement
on peut pas prendre parti dans cette
affaire puissance et un peu aussi en jeu
sauf que les gens sur les réseaux
prennent parti d'un côté et de l'autre
et les gens sur les réseaux de balance
des choses parfois terribles et c'est
vrai ce que tu as raison si c'est vrai
c'est abominable et si c'était ça l'est
encore plus aujourd'hui réfléchir à une
chose très importante c'est que quand on
est connu et je dis pas ça parce que je
ne suis que nous le sommes c'est que il
faisait très vigilants à ce qu'on peut
faire parce qu'un jour ça peut nous
remonter à la figure dans le bon sens
comme dans le mauvais sens et moi ça me
fout la trouille et moi je vous dis ça
me fout la trouille parce
qu'effectivement moi j'ai pas moi j'ai
des belles filles à la maison et je
mettrai celle de minutes j'ai des
belles-filles défi d'aurore je fais très
attention à la maison parce
qu'effectivement je sors de la douche je
veux dire un truc tout con je fais gaffe
des deux bien avoir une fermette un
peignoir
pourquoi parce que les kits qu'est-ce
qui me dit que dans dix ans elle va pas
dire castaldi il en fait un poil 2
la douche est qu'est-ce qu'on va dire
sont là c'est pour ça qu'il faut très
bien et ça nous fait ça donne tous nous
faire réfléchir à la façon dont se
comporte avec les enfants même quand on
pense que ça n'est pas grave je vais
bien sûr ce sont des jeunes filles
d'indiquer qu'à 16 ans il est cliquée à
maintenant et parfois quand je fais pas
gaffe oromo rape me rappelle alors
benjamin fait gaffe et elle a
complètement raison
et il faut tous qu'on soit bien vigilant
parce qu'effectivement je ne sais pas ce
qui est vrai ou skins est ce qu'il faut
dans cette histoire mais c'est vrai que
parfois les adultes on peut avoir des
comportements qui par la suite au fil
des ans se transforme alors soit en
vérité les gammes mais aussi parfois en
fantasme c'est josiane balasko qui a
pris parti dans cette affaire josiane
balasko maire de marilou berry et
belle-soeur donc de meeschart berry qui
a partagé un post sur instagram dans
laquelle elle prend parti pour coline
regard des soutiens colline berry
soutient que ni les rives et plusieurs
et derrière il ya carla bruni qui sont
des bd carla bruni-sarkozy qui a
directement interpellé josiane balasko
parce que vous êtes certaine que son
père est coupable
voilà et est donc et marilou berry a
porté hier aussi son soutien à sa
cousine la comédienne aurait eu vent de
cette affaire il ya quelques années se
seraient même disputés avec les chars
berry c'est ce que dit marine gris elle
expliqué à l'époque s'étrangler avec
richard pas ce qu'il a dit coline est
folle c'est n'importe quoi
je ne veux plus jamais voir cette femme
elle lui a fait remarquer je trouve ça
très bizarre comme réaction parce que la
première action à voir c'est allé lui
parler
allez d'avoir plutôt que de t'énerver et
prendre un avocat marie lou rey essayer
de recueillir différents points de vue
marilou berry avec ma grand mère j'en ai
parlé elle n'avait jamais répondu c'est
pas vrai il n'a jamais fait ça et elle
est ma tante ont toujours dit quand bien
même c'est pas dramatique non plus il
n'a pas violé il faut mettre un mouchoir
dessus voilà soutien de colis mairie
donc c'est le producteur romain rotman
qui a produit l'immense succès populaire
qu'est ce qu'on a fait au bon dieu il a
vécu de nombreuses années avec colleen
berry et il a eu deux enfants desquelles
selon lui une richard berry serait dans
le déni je comprends aussi que ce soit
impossible pour lui de se regarder
peut-être qu'on peut même se réinventer
le déni c'est ça il ya quand même une
probabilité qu'il soit ce qu'il dit et
bien sûr il ya hier on a eu tout le camp
monsieur richard berry et jean manson
notamment qui a tenu à réagir et s'est
dit horrifié par ces accusations et
shirel également on nous en avait parlé
tout à l'heure
la fille de jane manson
il alla dilara mois elle a commencé à me
harceler pour coco je confirme ses
mensonges que ne le ferait jamais il n'y
a pas eu de gestes déplacés de richard
il n'y a pas eu de jeux sexuels avec lui
et ma mère jamais aucun abus aucun
attouchements rien les mensonges de
colline sont impardonnables
des propos qu'elle a ensuite maintenu
sur bfm tv cet après midi à l'écran sa
mère aussi c'est normal par cette même
assis à regarder des paroles c'est le
seul témoin et j'avais 6 ans ou 7 ans et
je peux vous dire que rien de tel ne
s'est passé
jamais s'il avait senti la moindre chose
de pervers se serait imprimée en moi je
me souviens d'autres choses que c'était
pas un couple qui s'entendait que
c'était pas une une période très facile
mais de l'accusé et veut mettre en plus
dans cette scène horrible c'est grave
hein c'est grâce à s'allier vraiment au
tout le monde c'est pas la première fois
que je vois quelqu'un qui accusateurs
quelqu'un de proche que parce qu'en fait
il a de la haine et qu'il a quelque
chose à régler avec lui même
concrètement alors il ya énormément
énormément réaction sur cette affaire
selon les colons m les tweets en direct
bien entendu bien sûr je vais vous faire
pareil vous soyez ce qui accroîtra cette
affaire aussi c'est les réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui quand vous
avez un compte vous pouvez accuser
n'importe qui à écrire des horreurs sur
cette personne et je trouve que ce qu'on
a lu sur le compte de colibri je prends
au fond par parti ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre est évidemment mais c'est
vraiment abjecte et ça ressemble plus à
un dépôt de plainte qu'à une information
et qu'ils soient coupables ou non
richard berry tout le monde râle pas
beaucoup de gens auront lu ces
informations et ça ça peut les desservir
si le mal est fait sachez que c'est
grave à l'époque bercy le mal est fait
aujourd'hui ça va être très dur mais
c'est vrai c'est horrible
primo elle est bien en couleurs on
condamnera et si ces fous et voilà mon
cher idée qui ne pas proposer un film au
cinéma plaidoirie oui
moritz exact oui jouer en plus enfin il
ressort de scènes de gisèle halimi qui
est un grand ministre pardon il a je
trouve absolument désastreux que
l'espace médiatique empiète à ce point
sur l'espace judiciaire et vous imaginez
comment va se dérouler ce procès cette
enquête avec une telle pollution autour
c'est exactement tout ce que je déteste
tout ce que je pense qu'on aurait dû
éviter alors ce sont les indiens furent
des infos aux allemands alors ya richard
berry qui est peut également compter sur
le soutien de sa seconde fille joséphine
berry l'actrice a condamné d'elle-même
par action la rédaction du monde
expliquant que de son côté n'a jamais
été victime des faits reprochés à son
père il ne s'est jamais rien passé
il n'a jamais eu aucune il n'y a jamais
eu aucune ambiguïté et hier dans leur
des pros sur ces news avec le basket pro
alexandre arcady le réalisateur du grand
pardon a pris la parole mignon c'est
courageux de sa part aussi un alex
lagarde arkadi pour le 2-2 de prendre la
parole regardez ce qu'il est je suis
absolument atterré décontenancé
bouleverser ou à décharge le connais
depuis quarante ans j'ai connu sa fille
colling je pense que ça doit être le
reflet d'une grande souffrance
tout ça s'est passé au moment où richard
berry est devenu papa elle même était
enceinte
il ya un moment donné où les choses se
sont entrechoquées mais de là à pousser
les choses à ce niveau là c'est
absolument incroyable
donc aujourd'hui on a affaire à des
allégations qui sont totalement farfelue
voilà je voulais juste dire que j'ai
confiance en richard mais c'est avec sa
marque à nikki avec icade capri la
parole qu'est le courage de l'apprendre
minoui dans le cadre de l' enquête
préliminaire collins sera auditionné
très bientôt le neuf par la brigade des
mineurs qui s'occupe du dossier
et moi je réponds non la justice ne se
fait pas dans les médias mais faut pas
être dupe s'il n'y avait pas tout ça
aujourd'hui dans les médias pourquoi les
gens médiatise pour que la justice
travaille pour que ce soit sue saisi non
500 m à cyril mais des barrages
improvisés info j'entends oui mais oui
mais les deux parties pourront
s'exprimer devant la justice mais si
elle fait
dire ça et lui peut tout à fait répondre
c'est équilibré c'est parce que sinon
c'est enterrait faut pas être dupe là
dessus ils ne sortent pas à l'heure
actuelle pas vers le bas si le monsieur
là qui viennent parler en son nom est
pardon mais les combats dans là il
n'était pas dans la chambre c'est ça le
problème en fait c'est parole contre
parole
le souci est que le tribunal le tribut à
des réseaux sociaux c'est la personne
qui s'exprime le mieux puisque d'une les
faits sont prescrits et de deuil avait
que trois personnes apparemment au
maximum dans la chambre terrible parce
que peut-être qu'on ne le sauras tu mens
jamais vraiment ce qui s'est passé les
associations en compte en temps et qui
ont soif temps d'appel parce que grâce à
ce genre de divers très médiatisé il ya
des gens qui justement ça libère la
parole et ça permet aussi de faire
avancer les choses par rapport à l'image
iranien et vous comprenez donc qu'on
soit dans deux concours nous allons
monsieur ça sur les raisons
désolant mais ce qui me désole c'est
qu'on a un garde des sceaux qui ne
parlent pas sur la prescription
c'est ce à l'origine parce qu'on ne peut
pas porter plainte aujourd'hui parce que
c'est le prescrit et si on pouvait
porter plainte normalement on pouvait
aller au commissariat ont porté haut va
là et il ya le problème aujourd'hui
c'est la justice va beaucoup aimé
l'agencé monde c'est un autre souci les
travaux de mine mais non mais ça qui
entraîne justement cette justice dont je
pense a dit mme berry a laissé sa
précisément ses parents que cette radio
moi ya autre chose qui me gêne dans ces
affaires c'est que tous les médias en
parlent quand le scandale éclate on est
pas tout à fait de ce soir qu'un
parlement fait partie bien sûr oui mais
tout le monde en parle y compris les
chaînes info etc
quand il ya des révélations bien
graveleuses n'ya pas toujours de suivi
des procès renom on l'a fait quand on a
traité des dossiers comme ça mais
derrière si demain il a été acquitté ou
disculper il y aura moins de médias qui
vont en parler et en termes de
conversion vers d'y attirer sur elle et
c'est le prix qui sait déjà tout le
monde en parle
et si jamais il est disculpé va quitter
là ça va intéresser par exemple a servi
de refuge la faire durer 12 mois avec le
canular tout le monde en a parlé voilà
je vous rappelle que c'était un faux
témoins il ya eu un faux témoignage ça a
été prouvé disque n'a pas eu un effet
non pas un mais pourquoi est ce qu'il a
un prix de dire que vous étiez accusé de
ci de ça raconte quand vous êtes des
cons quand vous n'êtes pas juger
disculper c'est ça ça intéresse personne
ont fait mentir paris médias ils font
pas cela parce que ces mythes ou un set
ils font ça parce que c'est racoleur
une fois qu'il a été acquitté on va pas
en parler après pendant trois clowns
il est il est acquitté voilà on passe on
passe a été réglé là je suis devenir des
scènes découvrez les médias vous savez
très bien qu'ils vont en faire leurs
choux gras comme nous l'a c'est ce
qu'ont exactement en train d'enfer il ya
eu le faire il ya un intérêt on le fait
avec un intérêt coupable certes
peut-être mais on écoute la lé dinh les
différents protagonistes delà de la
sphère et eux mêmes y participe à sa
puisqu'ils répondent dans les réseaux
tard la brigade à ce compte pourquoi
josiane balasko elle a été bougés
marilou berry
si nous souhaitons mais bon cela dit je
viens chercher si vous même il marty
sipa ça et il témoignait aussi de leur
côté nicolas
je veux juste rappeler qu'avant les
réseaux sociaux il ya quand même une
affaire énorme qui était la première en
france qui a été la sphère allègre avec
dominique baudis président du csa qui a
été blanchi à des gens qui ont été
manipulés qui sont venus parler sur les
plateaux certains ont été payés et je
rappelle juste une chose il a été
blanchi mais il en est mort il ya un
moment donné un peu de pudeur un peu de
prudence
et attention aux désastres des deux
côtés parce qu'aujourd'hui colline on
dit quoi sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui elle est attaquée parce
qu'elle parle à 45 ans et les gens se
livrer pour quoi elle parle
géraldine l'a très bien dit il ya des
gens qui font un travail toute leur vie
qui vivent dans la peur dans le déni
dans le risque de faire du mal à la
famille dans l'emprise du bourreau a
détruit donc aujourd'hui il faut être
prudent par rapport à ce genre
d'affaires parce que vous l'avez dit
très justement c'est odieux des deux
côtés mais vous havrais même pas mais
par rapport à ce que tu dis tiffany si
demain c'est faux richard berry aura du
mal à tourner parce que les gens
passeront leur à dire oui comme sur la
ferme aux disent qu'il n'ya pas de fumée
sans feu
je conçois la faire sonner vous d'une
mère accusée d'inceste par son petit
fils qui a fait 10 une plus de dix ans
de prison va voir ce qu'on pensait à
tort et d'un beau fils patrick plets 77
mans
sans être vous choquer ou la stocker et
non 23 % merci d'avoir réagi là dessus